hey everybody and welcome to
an unbelievable episode of wild ride
with stevo what can i say we
are on a roll it's super bowl sunday
this weekend and we have none other than
the undisputed greatest wide receiver
of all time jerry rice man that's
something else dude
i mean we're on a roll dude so let's get
into it because this is incredible
ladies and gentlemen jerry rice
yeah dude
first i want to introduce you to my
co-host scott randolph how's it going
and up at the front of the van we've got
the gorgeous paul briskey
hello jerry how are you how about you oh
what's up what's up what's up dude
it's an honor to talk to you do you like
the name jesus and cleats
oh that's a little scary
you know i i don't i keep going michael
irvin said that back in the day yeah
mike mike and i we we used to always
follow each other and
if michael had a good day and
my day was not as good i was pissed off
so that was that that was that incentive
for me to work a little bit harder the
next weekend we sort of like we fed off
each other
but then he said jerry you you like
jesus and cleats i said man
i don't know about that one now yeah
that's it
now i i gotta tell you jerry man um i i
i'm determined to really make an effort
to not just
kiss your butt this whole time but
you're not making that easy man
you're not making that easy dude we we
just
did a google search we asked google
who is the greatest wide receiver
of all time okay and keep in mind that
when it comes to
basketball there's debate man when it
comes to
you know even the quarterbacks in the
nfl yeah there's debate there's no
debate man
google said jerry rice is
undisputed google said jerry rice is
the undisputed under the general period
there's that there's no debate there
it's that now
yeah not only are you undisputed
but you got so many records
as a wide receiver that you hold the
record for having the most records
oh man it's fantastic and then not
having
any uh you know bad
information out there about you
on or off the field you know like it's
just an
airtight ship with you man and uh and an
honor to do this
particularly right right before the
super bowl
but you know what with all the records
with all the accolades all of that it
was because of my teammates
football is a team sport and i had a
great group of guys that put me in a
position
where i could be successful in the
football field the greatest quarterback
joe montana then steve young uh
receiver john taylor you know brent
jones
roger craig all of these guys and we
work together as a group
as like almost just like an engine
together
and if i was not catching the ball if
i'm
blocking i'm i'm trying to spring roger
craig so he can go
60 to 80 yards so we sort of like
complimented
each other and i think that's why i was
able to uh put up
such big numbers is because of my
teammates
well that that the humble goat over here
that that's that's jerry rice we're not
worthy
that's epic and you know what what
fascinates me
is uh i i look back and at the
history of the nfl the dynasty of the
dallas cowboys in the early 90s when it
was just
a a just
chaotic just mess of cocaine and
alcohol and all these guys are partying
what am i talking about
it's well documented jerry it's well
documented that these guys weren't even
getting any sleep before the game they
were
partying like crazy and uh
i wonder like if uh if jerry rice
happened to be a part of that squad
what would that have look like i mean
well it wouldn't have been good
i can't assure you on that but
god man you know i was one of those guys
i was like i was really shocked when i
first came into the
nfl because i remember training camp in
brockland
sacramento and as a rookie first time
walking in the locker room
and i looked over and i noticed that
freddy solomon
and also fred dean they would go into
this little closet
this janitor closet and they would smoke
cigarettes
and i was like how how could you be an
athlete
and you smoked cigarettes so so that
left a walk over me i
wow i can't believe that because you
know i was one of those well-conditioned
guys that was all about
being in the best shape that you could
be in
and always performing at a very high
level
and uh and i think that's the reason why
i played for over 20 years
because i watched everything that i put
in my body and
my you know it's like my body is like my
engine
yeah and it's like everything every day
the way i practiced it was always 100
because i was conditioning myself
in a game situation where the fourth
quarter when everything is on the line
yeah
now everybody's tired you know you you
hear about michael jordan you hear
larry bird all these guys lebron james
uh steph curry they want to take their
last shot
they they want to be the one to win that
football game and that's the way i
looked at football
i mean they want to be the one to win
that game
and that's the way i look at football i
wanted to be that guy in the fourth
quarter
where i was in such great shape that i
could still perform at a very high level
well not just that
not just that's how i condition yeah not
just that but you know you get to the
fourth quarter and now you're
stepping it up a notch now you're
hitting your stride and that's uh
that that's some incredible incredible
skill warming up
i mean yeah it's hey guys my teammates
my teammates and uh you know the
opposing
uh uh players that i i went against
they thought i was crazy because fourth
quarter you're tired
so i'm bouncing around i'm jumping
around like hey look i'm ready to go now
hey because i wanted my fourth quarter
to be just like my uh
first quarter yeah so it was it was all
about my conditioning and
uh and i think that that just gave me
longevity for so many years
how much is it how much of that was
truth and like how much of that was like
getting inside the
the other player's head you know like
fourth quarter you're coming out you're
bouncing around
i i would say probably probably about
about 90 percent
cool yeah yeah yeah yeah you know guys
even during
the off season i i i would take two
weeks off and i'm right back into my
regimen
so so so so so it's like it's
it's not one of those things where i got
out of shape so
i would right after the season i would
take two weeks off then i'm back into
distance work like running the hill i
have this hill that you guys are invited
to
to run the infamous hill it's about you
know
it's uh it's about three miles up
uh three miles down is that the one you
told me about with the rookies
yeah yeah you guys hey you guys are
welcome to run this hill because the
last 800 meters
is straight up hill where where is it
it's right here uh it's right here in
the bay area it's right off of 280.
i remember when uh barry sanders also
uh terrell owes when he came to the team
you know he thought he was doing really
good
until my trainer told me uh coming up on
that last 800 meters
uh that i could go he couldn't believe
that i still had
a lot left in the tank where i could
finish the way i did
but you know that's the way i wanted to
uh
finish the fourth quarter and uh and i
was always
at my best you you look at a lot of
athletes i'm just gonna break this down
for you real real quick a lot of
athletes they can't perform
when everything is on the line you know
you look at playoffs you look at sunday
night football you look at monday night
football
uh super bowls and stuff like that i was
always
at my best and i think it had a lot to
do
with uh how i trained and and and
the type of condition that i was in yeah
it's a it's a mental
game man i mean a lot of people under
pressure
they choke you know and that's uh that's
a tough spot
to be in i mean how do you sleep the
night before a super bowl are you
sleeping
wait a second the greatest wide receiver
of all time would not sleep the night
before
super bowl man that's crazy and
his story only gets crazier
but speaking of crazy how about the way
i just
come out and say that i have a favorite
sponsor of this podcast
and i mean it i mean it with all of my
heart i love
hello like more than every other sponsor
of this podcast and i'm crazy to say
that
what is it hellotishie they make bidets
when you order them they come in a
small lightweight box it's very easy to
figure out
you attach it right to your toilet so
when you get done taking a dump
you just twist a knob and you get this
killer
blast of water to the stream just
it's like it pressure cleans your
butthole the catch line for this company
hello tushy is
stop wiping your butt start washing it
with tushy i mean i just
love the product i love the way the
company just
unapologetically posts the most grass
clever just awesome stuff on their
social media i love following them on
social media
and i love the way that they're taking
on valentine's day by saying there's no
greater
love story than the relationship between
your butthole
and your tushy bidet which i completely
agree with
so if you go to hellotushy.com
stevo not only are you going to get 10
off your order
but all these bidets come with a 60-day
risk-free guarantee meaning for if for
any reason you don't absolutely love
your bidet then you can send it back and
get a full refund
you also have a 12 month warranty
on it so i mean dude again
it's my favorite product to my favorite
company to sponsor this podcast so
please
support the podcast try this out and uh
you're gonna love it just like i do
to do that you go to hellotushy.como
and that gets you 10 off your order and
your butthole is just gonna
love it it's gonna be clean it's just
it's going to feel great
so now did jerry rice really not sleep
before
super bowls i don't
no sleep i haven't slept in 30 years
you know the reason why i don't sleep is
because i'm visualizing
what's going to happen the next day i'm
playing the game already in my head
because
the night before uh the actual game we
put in like the first 15 plays
so i'm going down that list and i'm
looking at my opportunities where i'm
uh you know i'm gonna be able to uh uh
be
well just impact the game yeah so i play
this game
over and over the night before
the day of the game or it's a long day
because the super bowl is not until late
that evening
and i can't eat because i'm so nervous i
got butterflies
anything that goes in my stomach is
gonna come back up
so it's a long day for me so i always go
over to the stadium
on the first bus so i go over to the
stadium
uh super bowl super bowl uh 23
uh i think it's against the cincinnati
bengals
i get to the stadium i put my uniform on
and i fall asleep
on the table hey because i'm tired i'm
gonna be honest
i'm tired i've been up all night and i
have played this game over and over my
head
my teammates are walking by and they're
saying man what's that with jerry this
is the super bowl
and he's sleeping
yeah man i had prepared the right way
and i was ready to go
and i went out and i was able to do some
great things on the football field now
also that was my
uh that was my uh most valuable player
uh football super bowl oh yeah so you
took a nap
and then woke up and got the mvp in the
super bowl
it was time to go to work man
that's fantastic man ah now you and i
met
now it's crazy that it's uh been been
over 10 years now but we met in las
vegas
at uh an mma awards i remember
and uh i remember thinking dude i just
met jerry rice dude that's epic
and what a nice guy so cool
and another thing is that we were both
on dancing with the stars you got in
there on that on
on season two yeah they didn't pay me a
no
what did they paint you i think uh
what was i think it was like 125
000. okay okay
he's like maybe they did pay me
oh damn that's so funny that's so cool
that's so funny you know you got extra
money because you did better
you made it all the way all the way to
the end
they keep they keep throwing more money
at you if you stay in yeah
you know it's like a fish out of water
oh yeah tell me about it i mean going
into that i didn't think it was going to
be that difficult
but then it's like all of a sudden you
know you're practicing for so many hours
and then when i got to the uh semifinals
i was going four in the morning
four in the evening and still i did not
win that ugly trophy
you got second place that's pretty good
man i don't like get a second place
jerry says i'm [ __ ] lost
but that trophy wouldn't look wouldn't
look good behind you i mean those
those all look pretty cool back there
yeah man
thank you this is like my little getaway
guys this is my bus from the pro
football hall of fame
epic you know it's like you know that's
the most uh
elite group you know once you get
selected into that but
you know all all the super bowls all the
playoff games uh all the regular season
games
you know it was something it was just
really special and it's something i'll
never forget because i never thought
you know that i would get the
opportunity from uh you know coming from
mississippi
and i got the opportunity to to live a
dream
damn damn right man and i heard you on
uh on howard stern you were talking like
you you weren't an athlete as a kid
until high school right
yeah i was playing hooky man i was
playing
that was your sport so i'm behind this
building and i'm just hiding out in the
principal walk
walks up behind me scared me he scared
me and he knows i can run really fast
but
we got disciplined a certain way in
mississippi
and and you guys know what i'm talking
about yeah so after that he wanted me to
go out for the football team and i went
out and
i just gave it my best shot and i became
a starter
and after that i went on to a
predominant black school mississippi
valley state
university where they threw the ball
like 90 at the time
and still not thinking that i would get
the opportunity to get drafted
then i get the call from the greatest
coach ever bill walsh
saying hey we're going to make you the
16th player in the
in the first round did it all of a
sudden i was like oh my god
is this really gonna happen so okay
i get drafted i'm the 16th player taken
i'm in jackson mississippi i go out to
the car wash and i'm washing my car
i watched my car everybody coming up
congratulating me doing all that because
now you gotta after uh later on in the
evening you gotta jump on an airplane
and you gotta
fly to san francisco so i had never
flown before
you're in the first round draft pick and
you said you went right over to wash
your car
what kind of car were you washing that
day i had a 300 zx
what is that i don't know hey it's like
a
it's a fast car it's red it's it's sort
of cool you know what i'm saying
it makes a statement when you're driving
it and it's like a magnum pi car
yeah so so so i'm i'm watching this car
and everybody's like man i can't believe
he's out watching his car right now
and he just got drafted yeah right wow
and
and uh so 300 zx what is that like a bmw
no no it's a smaller car man it's it's
you know it's sort of like it's it's
sort of flashy it's a little sports car
at mississippi valley state my uniform
had to fit a certain way
it was all about you know the colors the
green the red and all that
same way with san francisco i always had
to have a new pair of shoes
new pair of socks pants jersey had to
fit a certain way so it's all about
their appearance
right what'd you do with your first
paycheck did you buy a new car
no you know what i did i i bought my
parents a home
in starkville mississippi
that was like a dream come true for me
because i always had told my mom
that i would you know the first thing
that i would do is buy them a new home
and i was able to do that
and and you know it's like when you got
i had
well five brothers and uh two sisters
man it's like you get those calls
yeah you know you're always getting
those calls
so i appreciate you guys for helping me
out because now i can give them some
money
that's cool that that's so that's so
crazy now we read
you'd probably hear it all the time i
don't want to beat you up with uh the
same old
information but that your dad in
mississippi was a bricklayer
and they and they say that you uh
developed your
skills as a wide receiver by catching
bricks that your brothers were throwing
you
yeah i would be on this scaffold that's
about 20 feet in the air my brothers uh
they would throw the bricks up they
would throw them two at a time they
would
separate and i would snatch them out of
the air and
i think the thing is my father was a
bricklayer
and it was very demanding work and if i
didn't do my job
you know my father he was a tough guy
and
so i knew i had to work hard every day
but yeah you know being
able to uh snatch those bricks out of
the air
and just the meaning of hard work
i i think uh i got that from my parents
and then once i i got to the nfl all i
already had that drive
i mean i was gonna outwork you i might
not be the most talented guy
but my route running because i i used to
watch
uh dwight clark uh freddie solomon how
those guys would come out of their
routes
and get separation it's like
route running for me is like i want to
be able to be able to go
full board 100 and come out of my route
in two steps so it's almost like you're
dropping your hips you dropping
everything
and you're not making all those choppy
steps because if you make too many
choppy steps
defensive backs gonna be able to break
on the ball and they're gonna take it
the other direction so
my thing was all about my route running
being able to drop my hips and come out
of my
my cuts you know like i wanted to yeah
are you
are you talking crap the whole time are
you keeping pretty quiet when you're on
the field
oh no no i'm a quiet guy i don't talk
noise or anything
and but if a defensive back is talking
noise at me
the best way to get back at him is to
score a touchdown on him
he just scored another touchdown on him
yeah action should be louder than words
who was the best who was the best
crap talker in the nfl
god you know what
i would say dion dion sanders
he can make it seem like he's your best
friend but then
it's like all of a sudden if you fall
for that then he tries to take advantage
of you
so i i remember one game in atlanta he
was with the atlanta falcons
and and we had broke the huddle at the
line of scrimmage he wanted to shake my
hand
i'm like are you serious before they
snap the ball i said you want to snap
you want to shake my hand now i said
that's not gonna work we're enemies
right now
so it was always uh
i always had to put together my best
effort
he always challenged me but we look
forward to going against each other
because i knew he was
the best to ever play the game also
daryl green
the same way and you look for challenges
like that
and all you know like during the week
the way you prepare
the work that goes into it if you
don't practice hard during the week it's
not going to happen for you
during the football game all of a sudden
you can't
just decide okay i'm gonna turn that
switch on now you have to do that
over and over again during the week it
was all about the preparation
that put me in a position where i could
win on the football field
wow now after uh
after you retired wouldn't it have
seemed
like the the obvious move would be to
to get behind the commentating desk
like no you know i think i'm too
critical
i'll be way too critical because if
someone
is not loving what they do or they're
not giving 100
i'm gonna call that individual out you
know because
we get the opportunity where we live a
dream
and you get paid for it and you get an
opportunity where you can
entertain over 60 000 people
you can bring so much excitement to
one individual just by catching a
football
yeah i mean that's something special
i mean that just tells me that you would
have been even better at commentating
like you know but uh you know it's
interesting because
jerry writes i can't even wait for
people to find out that we got you
on our little wild ride rv podcast
is you know the [ __ ] weekend of the
super bowl yeah
i mean oh yeah tell us about what you
did for the super bowl this year
man i'm gonna tell you you're catching
burritos
you're pretty good i i uh frito lay with
marshawn lynch
i mean that's that's a real cool
commercial because they just
they just let marshawn do whatever the
hell he wants to do
and i learned it yeah so you know doing
that
being the burrito catch that was the
last catch for me over 100 yards
that thing was so high in the air and it
felt like a brick
when it hit my uh when it hit my hand
and god you know the thing about that
too is that 1549 receptions
that was 1550.
that felt like a brick yeah how crazy is
that
but it was very challenging and i knew i
needed to make that catch
we were uh at this high school and uh
everyone's still social distance they
did all of that but
people had they heard the word got
around that i was at the
at the football field so people started
to come out
so they were standing up against the
fence way
you know away from me and i knew i had
to make that catch for them
and i was able to do it in about eight
tries
wow that that uh catching the burrito
is a different commercial than the
frito-lay
oh yes that's the postmates commercial
and then we got the frito-lay commercial
yeah with marshmallows and you know it
brought a lot of quarterbacks it had the
mannings uh
dion sanders terry bradshaw was montana
uh dion sanders all that and had montana
in there montana and i
we just rehashing some old times you
know what joe man i'm gonna tell you
something about yoga
we were like just dorito chips
just trying to make field goals just
plucking it with our finger and stuff
like that
joe doesn't want to lose
i mean okay i'm like joe i played with
you man we're cool
okay i played with you i felt like i
needed goggles or something like that
because
he like he was trying to put my eye out
i mean this guy his accuracy is still
there so you know we had a fun time just
doing that commercial too
that's cool do you have any predictions
for the super bowl
i think it's going to be a great
football game and and
guys who would have thought this i mean
tom brady leaves
goes to tampa bay takes that team to the
super bowl
also they're the host team first time in
history
10th 10th super bowl this is the
opportunity for his seventh super bowl
ring
over 90 000 yards passing over 600
touchdowns or more
over 44 playoff games
and he's 43.
that's crazy all right
yeah could make every throw he could be
michael jordan he can look you off
and still throw the ball to you he got
great
weapons uh in tyrique hill uh
kelsey and and all of those guys and
i think it's going to be a very high
scoring game but if i had to pick
someone i don't know
well it can go either way the line at
last i saw
favored kansas city chiefs by three
points
so it's close you know it doesn't matter
i'm gonna tell you because the thing is
once you get to
the super bowl anything can happen the
team that
prepares the best way that's more
focused and ready to play is going to
win that football game
now will that be the chiefs or the bucks
uh i can't tell you but it's all about
the preparation
uh super bowl 23 your preparation
against the bengals
uh 24 against the broncos
then super bowl 29 against the chargers
we uh prepared a certain way we knew
that we were ready to play
and now you got to take that to the
football field
yeah and i would assume the mental game
is huge for that and if you think about
tom brady he's been in so many super
bowls
but the rest of that buccaneers team
hasn't necessarily played in all these
super bowls so like they might be like
oh it's the super bowl and
and maybe you know under pressure yeah
you know i talk about that it factor a
lot
tom brady got that it factor patrick
mahomes got that it factor
they make everybody better around them
and
i'm sure he's going to have that team
ready and
the intensity the speed of the game is
going to go to
a whole different level this is
everything here this
is why we play the game and you hear
guys say well you know i'm not gonna let
the super bowl dictate my career
i played professional football to win
super bowls
and i would have been very disappointed
if i hadn't you know won
a super bowl and i was fortunate to uh
to win three
yeah yeah how much do you think kovit
would have affected like just playing in
the super bowl without as many people in
the audience
would it not at all it doesn't matter
now
i i understand the the staple of the
game
will be for you know the fans to be in
the stands to enjoy this
but the players know that the players
are just like
say the horses from the kentucky derby
those horses know when it's race day
they know when it's time to go and those
players
you know when it comes sunday they know
that hey look everything is on the line
we have to play our best
football and we have to work together as
a cohesive group
because there is no int it's all about
teamwork
and if you do that you have a chance of
winning yeah man
you know i i got a question that i'm
really interested to get your take on
with
the you know all this
uh publicity all this new science about
the the concussions the cte
um it seems like
naturally now parents are are a little
bit
reluctant like they're not so sure about
putting their kids
into football leagues so do you think
that that affects
the the long-term future of the nfl
that fewer kids are getting into
football at a younger age
yeah you know i think the game is so uh
protected today
uh and because when we played it was
it was more like a a gladiator sport
because if you got hit and you and you
got knocked out or something like that
if you could answer what you have for
breakfast
the last play call or something like
that uh you were right back in the ball
game
now you look at you know what happens
when uh a player might get
concussed or something like that they
take his helmet they take him into the
tent
and they do all that now are parents
gonna let their kids
uh play football at a very young age i
don't think so now i think
they're gonna wait till later and uh
and you know where they're more
developed
right there's not gonna be any pop
warner and stuff like
that uh if if it's pop warner it's
probably gonna be flag football or
whatever
i think the sport is in a better place
now than uh
than it was back in the day because you
know we were uh
we was just out there trying to
establish ourselves and
we knew that it was going to be a
physical contest you look at
uh wide receivers now after five yards
you can't put your hands on them anymore
i remember it used to be a fight all the
way down field
and if i was on the left side and the
ball was being thrown to the right side
i was still getting hit
on the back side so you can't do that
anymore and i feel like the game is so
much more
well protected now that's good do you
think that
uh i was somebody i was talking to is
actually my fiancee's brother
saying yeah we told him that uh that
we're going to talk to you and
it's just all caps jerry rice is the man
you know and all this and uh
and and he had an interesting comment
that um that
jerry played in a different era where
they weren't throwing the ball the way
they throw it today
like what does that mean like are the
quarterbacks throwing the ball
different today no you know because it's
a wide the run pass option it's all
about the past
uh in the nfl now the ball is in the air
uh over 90 percent of the time
when i ran uh when i played back in the
day in my era
i probably got maybe five opportunities
where the ball was being thrown my way
and i had to capitalize off that
now you got guys getting over 10 or more
opportunities
right so you know the ball is in the air
more and
and i knew the importance
of every ball that was thrown to me
so i was one of those guys i didn't like
dropping footballs i could have a game
where
i i had five uh receptions
over you know 150 yards
and if i dropped one i would always
think about that one
so i never had that perfect game but
yeah you know i i
i think in football today these guys are
getting more opportunities
and uh and uh you know the ball is in
the air like 90 percent of the time
so that's what my brother my uh
soon-to-be brother-in-law
was saying was that not only do you have
all these records
as a wide receiver but that your records
mean more because you
you know that caught so many more passes
kind of got so many more receiving yards
than now where there's so many more
receiving yards to
to get yeah i get asked all the time
they said
how many balls would you catch in the
new era i never tried to compare the two
right because i i played i i played in
an era where
i mean you had to establish yourself on
the football field
it was going to be a dog play if you if
you went across the middle you had
linebackers and everything
linebacker's trying to take your head
off
and knowing that you know knowing that
defensive coordinators
all week long i mean defensive uh uh
it was yeah defensive coordinators they
prepare
to stop you all week and when you're
able
to go out there doing a football game
and still
be productive knowing that they have
prepared for you all week long
but they still can't stop you that's
really that's gratifying to me that
that showed me that hey look all the
work that i was putting in during the
week
uh is paying off me yeah that's cool i
have a quote i mean i don't know that
much about football admittedly
is there a reason that the game changed
in that way that went from a running
game to a passing
game you know i think they wanted
players from college to be
able to get acclimated quicker because
that's that's what they run in college
the run pass option okay
so now you get these guys uh uh to
graduate from college and go into the
nfl they're already
uh ready to play in and uh
so you know they can be uh productive
right from the start got you okay right
um
i i just want to ask you jerry this uh
this logo on your shirt
looks like it's the same logo on your
hat is that something that we need to
tell people about
is this is this a clothing line that
people need to be purchasing
yeah you know this is my clothing line
uh this is my goat feel
uh the greatest of all time but
hey no no no listen listen let me give
you a back story on
but the greatest of all time doesn't
just uh
it's just not for athletes
like doing this pandemic the front line
workers what you guys do
you know you guys are goats because it's
like you guys
are daring to be great so that's that's
my
my uh you know that's my
my belief behind goat feel and i always
wanted to put something out there was a
little bit healthier
and uh and i think i have done that we
started this about
a year ago we have four flavors and
uh we got four more flavors that are
going to come out uh later on but
in 20 years man it was all about what i
put in my body it's the same thing with
gold fuel
and you can go to goldfield.com
that's gold before and uh and what what
is group fuel is
is it an energy drink an energy drink
energy drink
uh so there's uh probably about 200
milligrams of caffeine
all right i love it so just like uh you
know it's just like a cup of coffee but
it's how much sugar
i don't sugar no
uh uh and uh
god it's crazy because the thing that
what we really added in here that really
make us different from uh any other
energy drink is that we put in cortisone
mushrooms
we noticed that these ghosts in the
himalayas that you know they were
running around they had all of this
energy and stuff like that
and we're like you know what we did our
research so we decided to incorporate
that
into gold field and uh it's just all
about the mindset and
and and i think with uh people coming
out of this pandemic they're gonna watch
everything that goes into their body
and they know for me my work ethic and
what i stood for over the years it was
all about health
right so so we're going to goatfuel.com
to purchase ourselves some of these four
flavors of energy drinks
hey buddy hey buddy you just give me the
uh the okay we we're sending it to you
i love it awesome yeah dude i i love it
man i'll get behind that
is it are there any retail
establishments
that have it on the shelf you know gnc
uh
we also uh we getting ready to do
something with uh
the ufc gyms yeah also
uh mitchell company i got about 37
counties
in uh mississippi that's cool and this
is really starting to catch on and
my thing too is like when i get up in
the morning it's all about my regimen
working out and stuff like that and i
like to inspire people
and and and a lot of my my goat family
they're on board man
you know they wait you know because i
like to respond back to them say hey
have a great
great day go because it's not just about
athletes man
it's about what people trying to do in
life right and if i can inspire them
to uh go out and be the greatest of all
time on that given day
i feel like i haven't done my part there
it is and what about the clothing line
man now i
kind of put it together that it's a goat
you go to the website then it has all of
that right on there
so that's the goat fuel clothing line
that you're wearing right there
yes all right man and uh and
and so you were pretty careful when we
asked you predictions for the super bowl
you didn't go one way or another are you
you stand out of it you don't want to
pick a team you don't have a fan
you know what because i i really don't
know
to be honest with you because i i think
once it gets to this uh this level you
know you have the experts they always
going to predict who they feel like is
going to win
and they're like supposed to be the ex
experts
right and they end up wrong right but
it's a different question it's a
different question
from uh who do you think is going to win
to ask you who do you want to win who
are you rooting for because what we have
here this sunday
is old versus new there's known two ways
about it you got the
the old tom brady you got the young
patrick mahomes yeah
it's a very diplomatic classy answer
jerry rice
and i i think part you know i like both
guys too part of me thinks man
i don't want to see 500 million dollars
go to waste
and let the young kid win but then part
of me thinks dude i'm an old guy myself
go
go geezers man go geezers tv 12. i can
guarantee you one thing hey
i can guarantee you one thing the team
that uh
prepares the right way that's focused
have paid attention to detail that team
is going to win
so which team do you think prepared the
right way
well i mean you got you got the kansas
city chiefs they're the defending super
bowl champions
and where where did where did the bucks
place last year
they make them go hey i would have to go
and practice with both teams
awesome man i'll tell you what i'm
actually going to be in tampa because my
buddy shaquille o'neal
is flying me out there to be a part of
this shack bowl
so everybody listening i want you to to
tune in to the shack bowl to watch me
and all kinds of celebrities mess around
and
and that's the pre-game show and then we
got of course the super bowl
six six pm eastern and uh be watching
for jerry rice's two commercials right
is it just two commercials
uh yeah it's just that a big uh frito
lake
oh okay but what about postmates that's
where you cut the burritos that not a
well you know what they started
aaronetta wow i don't know
i don't know if they're gonna god they
got that kind of money
they're saying yeah
st steve yeah and steve has another
buddy that wanted to say hi and he was
gushing about
you oh yeah i do my my buddy steve
austin stone cold steve austin
he wants are you serious yeah oh man
that is so cool man
hey let me know he's a goat man i gotta
i'm on an episode of his uh
show it's on the usa network this is
coming up on february 15th
he's gonna be actually the guest after
you uh next week we're putting you up
tomorrow my man
and then a week from tomorrow is stone
cold steve austin so we just
talked to him and he said oh man tell
jerry rice how much uh
how much i respect his his career how
much i love that guy
but in any case man it's been a real
real honor jerry thank you so much
and i thank you guys so much all i ask
is for you guys to make me look good
and that's it but i don't think we can
to
have the opportunity to be on the show
with you and
all you guys are ghosts man just keep on
living your dream and just keep working
harder
oh yeah i don't think we could make you
look bad jerry
and everybody who's still listening
everybody who's watching
if you're not watching the super bowl
this sunday with a goat fuel drink in
your hand
wearing a goat feel shirt then you're
just not doing it right this is not the
ghost
get to goat go fuel.com man
get over there and get get yourself
stocked up thanks
jerry okay peace jerry thank
everybody [ __ ] now
was that awesome or what for god's sakes
the undisputed
greatest of all time and i don't know
what else to tell you
like i spilled beans next week as steve
austin
stone cold steve austin t we're on a
roll man
everybody chill out there's
they're they're telling ya everybody's
excited for the super bowl around here
they're telling me that it's time for
some
treatsies
hey everybody thanks for watching